[Music]  and the congresswoman from New York's 14  congressional district I represent a  community that is overwhelmingly diverse  in all ways we have urban we have urban  communities communities I represent  constituents and what we saw today no  child should ever be separated from  their parents no child should ever be  taken from their family no woman should  ever be locked up in a pen when they  have done no harm to another human being  they should be given water they should  be given basic access to human rights  false notion the idea that we have to  choose between people is a false notion  [Music]  and I will accept that argument thank  you  [Music]